and for those who just joined were
playing with uh
for their increment so um flagging is
never really an issue i think that was
the best
best game i've played of the match so
far let's go for
for something a bit solid here
he had a fork really
we played 10 games so there are
potentially 14 games left
if the match if the match goes the
distance
i don't think i missed a mate in one
because his knight was protecting c8
this one yeah i don't think i did
should anyway not read chat
losing iq iq points by the minutes
i know you were promised losses and you
haven't gotten gotten them
i'm sorry about that i think it's
something about our our styles that
he's a good defender but not an
especially good attacker and then
i just end up being somewhat better in a
lot of games and
naturally and ends up being a bunch of
draws and also in this
in this game the position is very very
dry
and we could well see
see another one of those those draws
but i'm hoping eventually after we've
traded that
my pawn structure on on the queen side
is going to be
a little bit better
okay let's bring the knight around
possibly to
d6 and f5 attacking this one
also now that the
spawn is on g3 it's hard to play f3 so
it's a little bit harder to kick the
knight away
yeah let's just reroute the knights not
so worried about the c file here since i
got a good square for the knight in f5
and
my position is very very safe
i don't think he should have taken on d5
to be honest i think
that was good for me structurally
g4 yeah i spoke about knight five so we
decided to prevent it
it's very very very sensible
queen f6 rook d1
rp8 but it does have rook c6 there
maybe i'll go the other way try and
pulse on the c file after all
i also have the threat of queen before
potentially attacking
d4 and a4
yeah rook c6 makes a lot of sense
yeah as i change my mind i'm gonna move
the knight back
so that it's not it's not hanging
i think over the last two moves sorry
the last few moves his moves have been a
little bit more to the point than mine
maybe there's also a queen b5 there
okay let's let's exchange a few pieces
after all my pawn structure may be a
little bit better in the ending so
it's not like exchanges aren't
necessarily bad for me
56 there's rook c1 and queen d6
good thing this is not the arrow
championship yeah you're quite right
oh he probably made a move long time ago
i just didn't notice okay rick c5
yeah let's force that exchange
force it like force n huh
um
queen p5
queen b5 rex c1 take on f2 we can take
an a5 it
looks good for me
oh it goes for it
it's an interesting choice
certainly complicated complicating the
game
i've also got rp7 queen a5
taken c5 i win the exchange
and i have d4 later on
it's unclear but it looks good for me
let's do it
let's go
must be must be better for me
um
okay 25
b4 d3 attending queen e2
and if it takes i take an a2
hopefully invading
you can give a couple of checks but i
don't think it matters
yeah now i check and i take on b4
and i just win
queen d4 threatening one
good stuff